et
[Musique]
qui amène evans ont fait tout comme un
nom idiak of sky a oui ou llano vannes
ont signé margoulette sinon bah reach
evans
même si tu passes le premier tour y est
le troisième beaucoup ne passent pas le
3e
il passe le deuxième mais pas le
troisième alors celles qui n'ont
malheureusement pas passé le test j'ai
jekova chicchi tchenko à ce cas ça te va
irina nikitina grave être bien ce qu il
dit à nova les autres filles sont
invités à passer le deuxième tour
mademoiselle ngove cas merci
mademoiselle trop canova et et
mademoiselle andreyeva c'est tout
allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a plus de filles bien sûr parce que
toutes les filles veulent danser
elles veulent toutes devenir danseuse
étoile il n'y a pas beaucoup de garçons
ce sera plus dur pour elle comme à la
guerre où les hommes étaient de la chair
à canon et qu'on tuait pas autant les
femmes ici ce sera la même chose pour
elles elles seront la chair à canon j'ai
le trac
pourquoi as tu décidé d'essayer je sais
pas ça fait quatre ans que je suis les
cours de danse
[Musique]
et je voudrais que ma vie soit lui à la
danse ici ce sera difficile pour tous
les enfants
ils n'auront pas d'enfance ils n'en
n'ont déjà plus ils vont trimer et c'est
tout
la compétition est très sérieux
seulement 10 sur 100 qui restent seront
sélectionnés voilà c'est comme ça mais
nous allons essayer n'est ce pas comme
ça oui
ou comme ça apprend la jambe dans la
main gauche comme ça nous venons du
kirghizstan passé loin oui mais que
faire j'ai fait mes études à moscou
pratiquement avec nikolaï tsiskaridzé
ont volé ma carte d'étudiant c'est un
miracle que je n'ai encore pas me
reconnaissez oui j'ai 56 ans mais je
peux toujours mettre ma jambe ici
sérieusement sans problème excellent
brad pitt y ait débat
mademoiselle mambety a les bras elle est
là elle est là voilà voilà
elle est là vous allez à droite
remplissez le formulaire vous le donner
à vos enfants et ensuite vous sortez des
abricots ben oui on est la rentrée s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
toute mère veut bien sûr que sa fille
devienne danseuse étoile mais
malheureusement il y à une danseuse
étoile tous les dix ans parce que c'est
un ensemble de critères physiques de
capacité de charisme personnel
d'apparence quand tout est réuni et ici
ajoute encore la capacité à travailler
une star est née toutes les autres sont
des artistes ordinaire du corps de
ballet des employés du théâtre
olga tu viens d'où mais kaliningrad 11
ans tué en quelle année à l'école je
suis un sixième
tu as fait de la chorégraphie du ballet
de la danse j'ai fait de la gym bien tu
as fait de la gymnastique pendant
combien de temps ces temps j'ai déjà
perdu un an pour passer un cinquième et
on me prendra plus jeter à bas ce que je
serais trop grande pour entrer dans
cette école
je sais que j'ai un talent je sais que
je sais charmé les spectateurs c'est
pour ça que je suis sûr de moi mais j'ai
un défaut quand je suis stressée allé de
travers
j'ai peur de ne pas y arriver et j'ai
tellement envie
à présent s'échauffent et une fois que
ce groupe sort on se prépare on ne se
découvre pas trop pour l'instant je
viendrai vous chercher je vous emmènerai
dans les mains comme ça comme s'il y
avait un gâteau c'est tu n'as pas fait
le plier l eso à la première tentative
est finie c'est raté pour toi quand on
lance la polka il faut sourire montrer
qu'on aime danser et que la danse c'est
toute notre vie
l'élève par le talon et tire en arrière
je veux danser sur ce plateau mais que
maïa plissetskaïa tu exagères
si c'est possible ils doivent prendre
neuf filles et là il y en a déjà vendu 4
cours
bon
allez saute 3,4
c'est clair
je prendrai bien la brune mais ces gens
ne sont pas assez en dehors oui non on
est
et camées neva je crois la taille de
reculer vous trois ça suffit mais toi de
côté quand il faut choisir une fille
parmi celles ci
[Musique]
vous savez reste suisse à y aller tous
dans le couloir 6
attendez mais n'allez pas trop loin il
leur faut choisir une des quatre croix
fait était trop grande
l'autre plus petite est en fait ils ont
dit qu'il fallait choisir une ou une
fille rester là et on lui a dit de ne
pas partir ce n'est pas évident elle a
peut-être mal fait mais pourquoi tu
t'inquiètes seulement pas parce que tu
es l'une des meilleures rien n'est
encore perdu
on a essayé on a fait ce qu'on a pu
je saurai y est je crois que j'ai bien
danser
j'y ai mis tout ce que j'ai pu je sais
pas assez peut-être pas encore perdu non
elle a plein de la technique elle ne
grandira pas six ans de gymnastique
ils l'ont tellement fait travailler elle
ne grandira pas je crois que la première
fille la grande
il faut la prendre cette nikkei eva qui
a fait l'exercice de coordination elle
est douée j'étais sûr que je n'entrerai
pas dans cette école parce que j'avais
l'impression que les enfants qui étaient
ici il n'était pas comme les autres mais
j'ai passé toutes les étapes
apparemment j'étais doué nous sommes
obligés de dire non à beaucoup d'enfants
parce que nous n'acceptons que les
meilleurs
c'est une école où les conditions
d'enseignement sont très dures il faut
des critères exceptionnelle pour le bal
on va travailler les pas de polka et
patata mais pourquoi tu lèves la jambe
tu feras tu as ta allons ensemble tu
commences par un saut par une scie sonne
et rata saute saute bézy
non d'abord que je saute je saute et tu
comprends le mot sauter
errata c'est bien très bien
retiens ça c'est clair merci
ça
oui c'est déjà fini ouvrez bien les yeux
maman maman
[Musique]
ont reçu
il
c'est encore trop tôt pour se réjouir
mais quand même ta maman ultra kla le
corps grâce à un peu gronder quand je
suis sorti pourquoi parce que j'aimais
danser la polka elle m'a appris à danser
correctement qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire mais après quand j'ai
dansé elle m'a dit que c'était bien très
bien bravo
voici celles qui sont passées
à l'e10 est celle que son papa c'est
assez c'est qu'ils sont pas passés ici
celles qui sont passées
sport
[Musique]
je suis passé
sacha sacha sois pas triste
[Musique]
il soit patrice tout irait bien tu as
encore une vidéo toi
[Musique]
alors
elle est forte elle saute bien elle nous
a plu mais elle est très athlétique
nous avons eu des cas comme ça des cas
où la fille ne grandit pas et finit par
être expulsé
et là c'est une tragédie parce qu'il
s'agit déjà d'une danseuse de ballet
c'est vrai que nous l'avons gardé en
réserve nous avons gardé que trois
filles c'est souvent comme ça nous
sélectionnons 60 personnes et y en a qui
viennent pas honte a retenu ça ne fait
aucun doute
tu es une super fille tu as une belle
énergie prenez-la si vous en avez la
possibilité oui oui bien sûr d'accord
allez ne sois pas triste
tu es une battante merci et bonne chance
[Musique]
le train numéro 52 de minsk achats
pétersbourg arrive à la plateforme
numéro 3 côté gauche
les wagons sont numérotées à partir de
la tête du train
blocher nous avons des bagages plein de
choses pour la maison nous sommes
arrivés par le train avec lequel nous
étions partis on nous a appelés en
disant qu'elle avait finalement été
acceptée j'ai failli pleurer
j'ai ressenti une grande joie je me suis
dit que le bonheur était arrivé tout ira
bien
[Musique]
la réunion solennelle de la fête du
savoir comment olga regarde c'est
nicolas études car et césar aux mondieux
chers étudiants cher nouveaux venus je
suis heureux de vous saluer dans ce
célèbre bâtiment
j'espère que vous vous y plairait que
vous obtiendrez une profession parce que
vous êtes venus ici non seulement pour
étudier mais pour bénéficier de l'une
des formations les plus belles mais
aussi l'une des plus difficiles
j'ai beaucoup de fois répété cette
phrase lutter souffrir trouver ne jamais
baisser les bras
l'idée centrale ici est de ne pas
bonne route à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'avance
alors ça bah tu n'as pas encore de cours
non pas ça car tu veux en avoir
maintenant là ce sont les plus grandes
tu vois il y a des maigres il y en a qui
le sont moins attends je vais aller voir
[Musique]
ici on enseigne le ballet classique
depuis deux cent soixante dix huit ans
pour l'instant c'est le meilleur
apprentissage
je suis quelqu'un de très strictes
envers moi même j'ai grandi dans une
discipline très stricte du tout ma vie
d'écolier a été un exemple pour tout le
monde
richon quand j'étais le meilleur de la
classe à la première table militants
comme ce vol c'est quoi sa visite au
vestiaire et que je ne te vois plus ici
on ne se promène pas en chaussures de
danse hors des courts encore une classe
de filles bonjour nicolaï
appliquez-vous la classe de danse c'est
qu'en 3e et 4e
toi tu devrait grandir mange des
carottes
elles ne se rendent pas encore compte
dans quel établissement elles sont
pourquoi revoir ma main
ne pleure pas je t'appellerai une fois
que l'avion aura atterri vers 8h ne
t'inquiète pas avant d'accord la rue
tard dans la soirée fait ton limete
manuela leur classe prépare toi pour
demain demande à l'enseignante ce qu'il
faut repasser et n'oublie pas de coup de
route et chaussures de vallet
on est bien droit le dos bien droit et
qui met une demi heure à s'habiller là à
ce rythme on n'apprendra jamais rien de
toute sa vie
comment tu l'as nous et d'un double ou
quoi oui c'est à kaliningrad qu'on
apprend à faire le marin voilà eh bien
regardons vos sauts
[Musique]
on
les pieds les talons ensemble pourquoi
les coudes sont derrière
[Musique]
voilà très bien et maintenant la marche
inde 22 3
et maintenant plus lentement talons sur
le plancher sur le plancher est le talon
gauche va en avant en avant voilà j'ai
oublié comment tu t'appelles olga suis
trop tendue tu es une athlète est ici on
ne fait pas du sport ce ne doit pas être
du sport
tout doit être détendu et bo est sous
tension quand il le faut alors que toi
tu n'es que tension c'est pourquoi il ne
voulais pas te prendre parce qu'il se
disait que tu serais toujours comme ça
et j'ai dit non c'est une fille
intelligente je me suis portée garante
pour toi chez nous ce n'est pas du sport
c'est du ballet tu as compris ne prend
pas sa malle
[Musique]
ce qui d'un regard doit être naturel le
visage tourne là où tournent les yeux
non tu étais comme ça en m'écoutant
voilà comment voilà très bien ça
s'appelle le maniérisme
pour l'instant on apprend à être au
naturel et après on ajoutera de la
complexité
si vous ne faites pas vos profs d'ici la
fin de l'année vous serez expulsé très
bien les filles vous savez où aller
je ne sais pas dans quel salon sera
demain
[Musique]
au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
6on que nous avons la répétition à une
heure nous quittons l'académie et le
spectacle dure jusqu'à 8 heures nous
revenons il faut faire ses devoirs et
aux pensionnats l'heure de coucher et à
10 heures on revient on est fatigués et
le lendemain on recommence du sein d un
pôle oui de la chaire de la chaire oui
des ampoules jusqu'à la chair oui quand
nous arrivons après la répétition il se
peut que personne nous parle absolument
personne personne les gens passent juste
comme ça nous sommes entré dans le
vestiaire et ils sont là comme ça ça
arrive aussi à olga de se vexer vous
savez il arrive que voilà mais après
elle me parle quand même mais tout va
bien nouveau ce qui m'arrive de pleurer
nos mères nous manque et on se
réconfortent mutuellement on sympathise
on se plaint quand on ne l'a pas choisie
pour le pas de 3 elle n'a pas arrêté de
me dire on n'a pas sélectionné m'a pas
sélectionné
et je lui disais ne t'inquiète pas tout
peut encore changer on choisit celles
qui sont déjà prêtes qui ont déjà d'or
c'est parce qu'une fois sur les pointes
avant la kabylie celle qui danse bien
qu'ils ont du talent artistique qui ça
sourire et on a fait tout ça très bien
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
pis je ne veux pas qu'il y ait deux fils
là bas du côté de vache papa à gauche
l'autre ce qui met toi au milieu et du
côté de moussa à droite les poupées les
y aiderons à tirer les enseignements et
les poupées allons-y vite dans la salle
je suis trop gros maria je ne
m'attendais pas à cela de vous
je choisis avant tout ce qu'ils sont
capables techniquement d'interpréter tel
ou tel rôle
et quand je commence à travailler avec
des enfants
je répète tout le temps aux parents car
la carrière se fait au théâtre et oui la
carrière se fait au théâtre à l'école on
ne fait qu'apprendre ont fait pas
carrière à l'école oublier sa route
on vérifie la barre les jeunes ou les
genoux vont en arrière tirer et on
soulève allait aller plus haut plus haut
toutefois soulevé la jambe soulevées sur
le genou allez-y sous le genou
allez allez allez allez voilà voilà le
pied tu l'a pas saisie soutien soutien
soutien tourner en dehors et olga les
épaules ne vont pas derrière on garde la
cinquième position
on me laisse la barre et vérifie et
[Musique]
oui c'est difficile c'est difficile tout
le monde n'arrive pas à soulever la
jambe c'est mieux elle s'adapte petit à
petit elle est malade maintenant elle a
été malade pendant une semaine
chez nous on ne peut pas manquer les
cours une semaine manqué ses deux
semaines pour revenir au niveau
elle ne s'attendait pas à de telles
difficultés a tout ce qu'il faut faire
il faudrait chaque jour se surpasser
comme la première fois qu'il faudra
s'appliquer
elle ne s'y attendait pas voilà pourquoi
elles ont beaucoup de problèmes je ne
suis pas contente d'elle en général
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
ce n'était pas très à l'aise avec casse
noisette c'est ça est le porte et
c'était facile si au contraire
oui parce que l'autre était plus lourd
est celui ci plus léger et a mis un peu
de temps à le prendre pas les faire au
plus vite
et quand tu fais le plier il faut fixer
son regard sur lui et pas regarder dans
la salle tu comprends et toi tu étais
tout le temps comme ça
la deuxième fois tu regardais et sinon
c'était bien je sais que je pourrai
faire encore mieux si je m'applique al
ghad ans aujourd'hui olga oui et je vous
la poupée je crois que c'est elle par là
elle a le trac
[Musique]
et qui dans ce mariage
oui la danse le rôle de maria fait de
ton rêve oui je suis contente pour elle
moi je danse la pop est dans le deuxième
acte
alors les poupées sont habillés les
poupées habillées vous tu l'enlèves pas
je la porte à après je fais comme ça
c'est ça là je ne sais pas c'est toi qui
doit connaître son rôle
ouais ouais je sais ce que je fais je me
change pour la bataille c'est ça bien
sûr l'habilleuse va prendre aux costumes
il faut aussi prendre les pointes
bien sûr
maria bien ici
j'étais pas triste parce que je m'y
attendais anna fait du ballet depuis
très longtemps elle fait des pointes
elle devance très bien et moi je viens
d'arrêter la gym je ne suis pas un corps
habile pour les pointes
je ne connais pas tous les mouvements du
ballet j'ai décidé de pratiquer autant
que possible et essayer l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
un simple fait que je danse et toujours
comme un conte de fées je n'arrive
toujours pas à croire que je danse on
sait le pa2 donne la main tu vas toi tu
comprends mais tu es là sur les pointes
ton pied haut sur les points pourquoi tu
fais comme ça dis-le moi allez avance
pourquoi tu avances comme ça
allez vas-y tu n'as pas honte
il verra tu n'as pas honte et puis c'est
ta première fois sur scène c'est
seulement de ce côté du rideau que ça
ressemble à un conte ici c'est avant
tout du travail présente plus comme lors
de leur premier jour à l'école je leur
ai expliqué n'est ce pas anna le moment
de travailler était venu il n'y avait
pas de miracle c'est tout chaud
d'origine il faut travailler beaucoup
pour présenter ce miracle sur scène
voilà c'est comme ça
merci de rien tu as compris a laissé
bien j'aime s'il est encore trop tôt
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]